This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. When you're trying to invent a new product, or write a screenplay, or come up with a new way to do something at work, it's fun to focus on the possibilities. It's enjoyable to have brainstorming sessions, throw ideas up on a whiteboard, daydream.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。当你试图发明新产品、写剧本，或者想出在工作中做事的新方法时，把注意力集中在可能性上是很有趣的。进行头脑风暴会议、把想法写在白板上、做白日梦，都是令人愉快的事。
Very often, however, these brainstorming sessions don't lead to anything tangible. Teams fill up walls with sticky notes about creative possibilities and suggestions for improvement, but none of them are actually implemented. If you've been part of an organization that does this, you might get the sneaking suspicion that you are not engaged in innovation, but in what some researchers call innovation theater. This is not to say that ideas are unimportant, but it is to underscore that when it comes to building something new, what really matters is execution. For the last few weeks, we've been exploring the science of innovation.
然而，通常情况下，这些头脑风暴会议不会带来任何实质性的成果。团队的墙上贴满了关于创意可能性和改进建议的便签，但没有一个真正得到实施。如果你所在的组织做过这种事，你可能会产生一种隐隐的疑觉：你们从事的不是创新，而是某些研究人员所说的“创新戏剧”。这并不是说创意不重要，而是要强调，在打造新事物时，真正重要的是执行力。在过去的几周里，我们一直在探讨创新的科学。
We've examined how successful entrepreneurs are great at something called effectuation. We've looked at our attitudes about the role of genius in success and how cultures of genius can undermine our growth. If you missed those episodes, I strongly recommend you listen to them in this podcast feed. Today, in the latest installment of our Innovation 2.0 series, we explore the science of execution. How to move from innovation theater to actual innovation, this week on Hidden Brain. We all have them. Small frustrations that make our lives just a little bit more difficult. Like standing in a long line at the grocery store or getting too many emails. Not being able to reach a customer service rep when you have a problem.
我们研究了成功的企业家如何擅长一种叫做“效果化”的方法。我们探讨了自己对天才在成功中扮演的角色的态度，以及天才文化是如何破坏我们成长的。如果你错过了这些节目，我强烈建议你在本播客订阅源中收听它们。今天，在我们“创新2.0”系列的最新一期中，我们将探讨执行的科学。如何从创新戏剧走向真正的创新，本周的《隐藏的大脑》为您揭晓。我们都有这种经历。那些让我们的生活变得稍微困难一点的小挫折。比如在杂货店排长队，或者收到太多电子邮件。遇到问题时无法联系到客服代表。
At Stanford University, psychologist Bob Sutton studies these frustrations, the annoying bureaucracies we encounter when dealing with companies, institutions, and organizations. Bob Sutton, welcome to Hidden Brain. Oh, Shankar, it's great to be here. I'm happy to talk to you. I want to start with a personal story that I think many of our listeners can relate to, Bob.
在斯坦福大学，心理学家鲍勃·萨顿研究这些挫折，也就是我们在与公司、机构和组织打交道时遇到的令人烦恼的官僚作风。鲍勃·萨顿，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。哦，尚卡尔，很高兴来到这里。我很高兴跟你聊聊。鲍勃，我想从一个我想我们的许多听众都能感同身受的个人故事开始。
It involves a conflict that you had with your cable provider. Tell me the story of what happened. Well, I mean, there's a sad part. So my mother passed away, but then her partner was still living in the house, and there was all these problems that we could not have cable TV for him. And I kept calling them. And there was all these problems that we could not have cable TV for him. And I kept calling them, they claimed they'd fix it. I would go through these phone trees over and over and over again.
这涉及到你与有线电视供应商之间的一次冲突。跟我讲讲发生了什么事吧。嗯，我是说，这其中有一段悲伤的经历。我母亲去世了，但她的伴侣仍然住在房子里，结果出现了各种各样的问题，导致我们无法为他安装有线电视。我一直打电话给他们。结果出现了各种各样的问题，导致我们无法为他安装有线电视。我一直打电话给他们，他们声称会修好。我一次又一次、一遍又一遍地拨打那些语音菜单电话。
It was just driving me absolutely, you know, in all the stress and grief of my mother's death that I was dealing with. This was a part of it. And after probably 10 different phone calls and phone trees and people making mistakes, I went and I complained and I did it on Twitter, now X. And this person who is a board member found out about it and he said, I will help you. And then magically I got the VIP privilege line, one phone call, fixed immediately, all fees waived. And in fact, later on, about three weeks later, my son just wanted an upgrade up in San Francisco
这简直要把我逼疯了，你知道的，我当时还要应对母亲去世带来的所有压力和悲伤。这也是其中的一部分。在经历了大概10次不同的电话、语音菜单和别人的失误之后，我去找他们投诉了，我是在当时的推特（现在叫X）上发的。然后，一位董事会成员发现了这件事，他说：“我会帮你。”接着，神奇的事情发生了，我得到了VIP特权专线，打了一个电话，问题立刻解决，所有费用全免。事实上，大约三周后，我儿子只是想在旧金山升级一下套餐，
and I called them. They came to his apartment for no charge. They didn't charge them for the new equipment. It was like we were moved from the regular person's experience to the VIP lounge, and we had the privilege to be protected from the inconveniences that the little people suffered from. Bob had always been interested in how organizations run.
我给他们打了电话。他们免费来到他的公寓。他们没有收取新设备的费用。就像我们从普通人的体验被移到了VIP休息室，我们有特权免受普通人所遭受的种种不便之苦。鲍勃一直对组织的运作方式很感兴趣。
So instead of simply reveling in his newfound VIP status, he looked into why the cable company was giving some customers the VIP treatment. He discovered that the goal of this ultra-secret club was not about pleasing customers. It was meant to serve the boss class. When well-connected people called in favors or irate customers created trouble, having a VIP lounge to send them to bought executives peace and quiet. And I sort of compare that to well, he's one of this guy named Carl Lieber. He's been head of many companies. At one point, he
因此，他并没有沉浸在自己新获得的VIP身份中，而是深入调查为什么这家有线电视公司会给予某些客户VIP待遇。他发现，这个高度机密的俱乐部的目标根本不是取悦客户。它是为了服务老板阶层。当有人脉的人打电话求助或愤怒的客户制造麻烦时，有一个可以打发他们去的VIP休息室，就能为主管们买来平静与安宁。我把这与另一个人作比较，他叫卡尔·利伯。他曾担任过许多公司的负责人。有一段时间，他
was head of supply chain of Home Depot. And there were all these problems at Home Depot. He not only would go shopping anonymously, he would actually work the midnight shift with the workers loading and loading boxes to try to figure out where the supply chain problems actually happened. To me, there's a big difference between being in the VIP lounge and being protected from the inconveniences, if you will. Bob argues that one reason companies and organizations drop the ball when it comes to execution
担任过家得宝的供应链负责人。家得宝当时存在各种各样的问题。他不仅会匿名去购物，还会实际上和工人们一起上夜班，搬运箱子，试图找出供应链问题究竟发生在哪个环节。对我来说，身处VIP休息室并免受不便之苦，与亲历现场之间有着巨大的差异。鲍勃认为，公司和组织在执行力上掉链子的原因之一是
is that the leaders of companies are too far removed from the experiences of customers. But that is far from the only reason. Some organizations are so complex that getting different silos to talk to one another is next to impossible. He cites the work of Stanford researcher Melissa Valentine, who studied a cancer center. And what her research found was that patients suffered from what she called the cancer tax, which means that when you have a relative who gets cancer, it's so hard to glue together all the different parts of the treatment that it falls to the patient. And so the cancer center she studied had excellent doctors, individual departments, but you need
公司领导层与客户的实际体验脱节太远。但这绝不是唯一的 原因。有些组织过于复杂，以至于让不同的部门（壁垒）互相沟通几乎是不可能的。他引用了斯坦福大学研究员梅丽莎·瓦伦丁的一项研究，她研究了一家癌症中心。她的研究发现，患者遭受了她所谓的“癌症税”，这意味着当你有一位患癌症的亲属时，要把治疗的所有不同部分拼凑起来是如此困难，以至于重担全落在了患者身上。因此，她研究的那家癌症中心拥有优秀的医生和独立的科室，但当你身边有人患癌症时，你需要
all these different services when you have somebody who has cancer. And one of my neighbors, her brother is a doctor and their mother got cancer. And the doctor said, the fact that I'm a physician actually didn't help me that much navigating through the system because there's so much fragmentation and lack of communication between silos and occupations and so forth. So sometimes it's structural, too,
所有这些不同的服务。我的一个邻居，她的哥哥是个医生，他们的母亲得了癌症。那位医生说：“事实上，身为医生的事实并没有在穿梭于这个系统时给我带来多大帮助，因为各个部门和职业之间存在着太多的碎片化和缺乏沟通，诸如此类。”所以有时候这也是结构性的问题，
and it's very difficult to overcome for anyone. One organization Bob studied revealed a problem that he calls executive magnification. A lot of times senior executives complain there's resistance to change. When I come up with an idea, people push back against it. But all of us who are in hierarchies, whether we're baboons or humans, we tend to focus very heavily on the moves and actions and preferences of those in power. And it's just adaptive because those in power,
对任何人来说都非常难以克服。鲍勃研究的一个组织揭示了一个他称之为“高管放大效应”的问题。很多时候，高级主管们抱怨说变革存在阻力。每当我提出一个想法时，人们都会推诿抵制。但我们所有身处层级结构中的人，无论是狒狒还是人类，都非常倾向于高度关注那些掌权者的举动、行动和偏好。这只是一种适应性行为，因为掌权者
they can give us rewards and punishments of all kinds. And this was a new CEO. And one of the first meetings he went to, and this is CEO of a Fortune 10 company, a very large company, and he gets to an early meeting and he just comments, where's the blueberry muffins? And there's just an offhand comment, and then somebody put in his notes, you know,
可以给予我们各种各样的奖惩。这是一个新任CEO。他参加的第一次会议之一——这是一位财富10强公司（一家非常大的公司）的CEO，他早早来到会议室，随口说了一句：“蓝莓松饼在哪里？”这只是一句随口的话，然后有人在他的笔记里记下了，你知道的，
prefers blueberry muffins, and he couldn't figure out for years why every meeting he went to, there were huge piles of blueberry muffins. And imagine all these poor underlings just being really nervous because otherwise they'd have an unhappy CEO Now did the CEO actually won blueberry muffins at all these meetings No Maybe at that moment, but that wasn't particularly important to him But but it's a reminder for people who are in power that there's all sorts of psychological research
偏爱蓝莓松饼。接下来的几年里，他一直想不通为什么自己参加的每一个会议上，都有堆积如山的蓝莓松饼。想象一下，所有这些可怜的下属都极其紧张，因为否则他们就会有一个不高兴的CEO。那么，这位CEO真的希望所有这些会议上都有蓝莓松饼吗？不。也许在那一刻是想的，但这对他来说并不是特别重要；但这提醒了那些掌权的人，有各种各样的心理学研究表明
about attention turns up the hierarchy. And so you've got to be careful. And even when you're sort of thinking out loud to say, I'm thinking out loud, I'm not asking you to do anything. And in a more sort of serious example, some 30 years ago, I did research with the 7-Eleven company. So the then CEO, he walks into a 7-Eleven store
注意力是向上级层级汇聚的。所以你必须小心。甚至当你只是大声思考时，也要说：“我在大声思考，我并不是要求你们做任何事。”在一个更严肃的例子中，大约30年前，我与7-Eleven公司合作过研究。当时的CEO走进一家7-Eleven门店，
and a clerk is rude to him. He comes back to the office and he kind of has a temper tantrum about how unacceptable it is. And some of his underlings say, oh my goodness, we've got to do something about the courtesy in 7-Eleven stores. And they started all of these underlings say, oh my goodness, we've got to do something about the courtesy in 7-eleven stores and they started all of these different contests some of which I was involved in evaluating and the idea was to provide
一个店员对很不礼貌。他回到办公室后，大发雷霆，认为这种行为多么不可接受。他的一些下属说：“噢天哪，我们必须对7-Eleven门店的服务礼貌做点什么。”于是他们开始——噢天哪，我们必须对7-Eleven门店的服务礼貌做点什么，于是他们开始策划各种各样的竞赛，其中有些竞赛我也参与了评估，其核心理念是为
Incentives for every clerk in every 7-eleven store to smile establish eye contact and to say thank you to every customer and They did all this analysis and in the end and this is included in some of the research I was involved in, we were able to show there was virtually no relationship between the courtesy in a seven 11 store and their sales. People want to get in and out quickly and they don't want a rude clerk. That's all they want. And after spending millions of dollars, including they had a thanks a million contest that the owner of one seven 11
每一个7-Eleven门店的每一个店员提供激励，让他们对每一位顾客微笑、进行眼神交流并说谢谢。他们做了所有的分析，最后——这包含在我参与的一些研究中，我们能够证明，7-Eleven门店的服务礼貌与其销售额之间几乎没有关系。人们只想快进快出，他们不想要一个粗鲁的店员。这就是他们想要的全部。在花费了数百万美元之后，包括他们举办了一个“百万谢意”竞赛——如果某家7-Eleven
store or manager, if they had perfect courtesy, they entered a drawing and somebody won a million dollars for the courtesy in their store. And this was just largely the effect of executive magnification. The CEO hadn't realized that this sort of crazy thing happened. ["The New York Times"] ["The New York Times"]
门店的所有者或经理保持了完美的礼貌，他们就可以参加抽奖，有人会因为他们店铺的服务礼貌而赢得一百万美元。这在很大程度上只是高管放大效应的结果。这位CEO并没有意识到这种疯狂的事情会发生。['《纽约时报》'] ['《纽约时报》']
["The New York Times"] ["The New York Times"] thing happened. As you can see, what customers and clients perceive as a badly run organization can be the result of many different internal forces. Sometimes managers want to ignore unpleasant feedback. At other times, companies become hyper focused on one issue, like smiling at customers or making blueberry muffins available at every meeting when those things don't really matter. A few years ago, Bob wrote an entire book about another reason groups fail to execute on good ideas.
['《纽约时报》'] ['《纽约时报》'] 事情发生了。正如你所看到的，客户和消费者认为运营不善的组织，可能是许多不同内部力量共同作用的结果。有时，管理者想要忽视令人不快的反馈。而在其他时候，公司会过度专注于某一特定问题，比如对顾客微笑或确保每次会议都有蓝莓松饼，而这些事情实际上根本不重要。几年前，鲍勃写了一整本书，探讨团队未能将好想法付诸实践的另一个原因。
The book's title has, shall we say, salty language. For better or worse, in 2007, I published a book called The No-A**-Rule, which I thought was going to be my worst-selling book, and it's turned out to be my best-selling book. And the argument that that book makes, that when people leave others feeling demeaned, de-energized, disrespected, that it's actually bad for business.
这本书的书名用词可以说相当“辛辣”。不管好坏，在2007年，我出版了一本名为《拒绝混蛋守则》（The No-A**-Rule）的书，我原本以为这会是我销量最差的书，结果它成了我销量最好的书。这本书的核心观点是，当人们让其他人感到受贬低、被抽空精力、不被尊重时，这对生意其实是百害而无一利的。
When people feel that way, they perform less well. Their health is negatively affected. One of the key things is that they're not willing to go the extra mile. And there's large-scale studies, for for example in fast food chains that when you've got a nasty manager of a fast food chain that people are more likely to steal, more likely to quit. So if you have leaders throughout an organization who treat people with disrespect that that ends up being a problem.
当人们有这种感觉时，他们的表现就会变差。他们的健康状况会受到负面影响。关键的事情之一是，他们不愿意付出额外努力。有大规模的研究表明，例如在快餐连锁店中，如果你有一个讨厌的快餐店经理，员工就更有可能偷窃、更有可能辞职。因此，如果你在整个组织中都有以不尊重态度对待员工的领导者，这最终会成为一个大问题。
We can talk about whether people who are jerks get ahead in some systems that actually might be possible in some systems but when you work for somebody who leaves you feeling that way, I think that the evidence is quite clear that it undermines the performance of the organization or team. And there's also been evidence that suggests that even when you have one person on a team, even if the team is quite large, but you have one person on the team who really is a negative personality or a difficult person to work with or just an unpleasant person, that can damage the relationships and the camaraderie of the whole team. Yeah.
我们可以讨论那些混蛋在某些系统中是否能飞黄腾达——在某些系统中这确实可能是可能的，但当你为某个让你有这种感觉的人工作时，我认为证据相当清楚，它会破坏组织或团队的绩效。并且还有证据表明，即使你的团队中只有一个人，即便团队规模相当大，但只要团队里有这样一个真正性格负面、很难共事或者仅仅是个讨厌鬼的人，就能破坏整个团队的关系和同事情谊。是的。
So, there's two reasons, at least one is, there's a lot of evidence that negative emotions are more contagious than positive emotions in general. And then the other thing, which some studies show, and I think if you look at more anecdotal evidence you'll see if you talk to a boss and say, who do you spend most of your time with? Very often they'll say, I spend 90% of my time dealing with the 10% who are most difficult. And so that's the sort of uniform sort of issue that happens throughout organizations. So yeah, and it's funny because at one point
所以，原因有两个，至少其一是，有大量证据表明，总的来说，负面情绪比正面情绪更具传染性。另一个原因是，一些研究表明，如果你看一下更多轶事证据，就会发现，如果你去问一个老板：“你大部分时间都在和谁相处？”他们往往会说：“我90%的时间都在应付那10%最难缠的人。”这就是整个组织中普遍存在的同类问题。所以，是的，而且很有趣的是，在某一个时间点
I thought maybe it might be good to have maybe one low status jerk in a team or organization to show how not to behave. But I've since come to the belief that they're so difficult that it's better to get rid of them, although it's pretty difficult. I bet all your listeners can tell you. Yeah. I've been on many search committees for many positions, and I think increasingly many people
我曾认为，在团队或组织中也许留一个低地位的混蛋可能会有好处，用来展示不该如何表现。但我后来逐渐确信，他们太难缠了，最好还是把他们赶走，尽管这相当困难。我敢说你所有的听众都能附和这一点。是的。我曾参与过许多职位的招聘委员会，我认为越来越多的人
say, even when you have someone who's incredibly talented and smart, if this person is a truly unpleasant person, it's probably not worth it to bring them on the team. Yeah. Yeah. it's probably not worth it to bring them on the team. Yeah, yeah. Well, so one of the tests that I like to use, and if you look at a place like Microsoft, I believe they've had a transformation around this, is I ask them, if you are a superstar and a jerk, do you get ahead?
会说，即使你遇到了一个才华横溢、聪明绝顶的人，如果这个人确实是个讨人厌的家伙，把他招进团队可能也得不偿失。是的。是的。把他招进团队可能也得不偿失。是的，是的。好吧，我喜欢用的测试之一——如果你看看像微软这样的公司，我相信他们在这方面经历过转型——我问他们：“如果你是一个超级巨星却又是个混蛋，你能高升吗？”
And there are some organizations, if you are a superstar and a jerk, under the old Microsoft, it was actually rewarded to treat, to try to push down fellow coworkers. And now the kind of people who get ahead at Microsoft, and they're quite explicit like this, are the people who do good work and who help others along rather than stomp on them on the way to the top. And a little bit of competition, or even a lot of competition in the culture can be very
在某些组织里，如果你是个超级巨星却又是个混蛋，在旧微软的体制下，虐待、试图打压同事实际上是会受到奖励的。而现在，在微软能够高升的人——他们对此非常明确——是那些工作出色、在通往顶峰的路上不仅不踩踏别人，反而一路上帮助他人的人。文化中有一点点竞争，甚至有大量的竞争，可以是非常
useful. And a little bit of competition, or even a lot of competition in the culture can be very useful, but the question is how you treat your coworkers can have a big effect. As Bob looked at these many disparate examples, he started to see that there was one common theme that connected all of them. It was the idea of friction. It might be helpful to explain this with an analogy. Let's say you're an engineer designing a car. You wanted to run as smoothly as possible, but this doesn't mean that you want to reduce friction in everything the car does. When a driver hits the brakes, friction is what makes the car stop. If a motorist yanks at the steering wheel and it spins around without any resistance,
有用的。文化中有一点点竞争，甚至有大量的竞争，可以是非常有用的，但问题是你如何对待同事，这会产生重大的影响。当鲍勃审视这些许多截然不同的例子时，他开始看到有一个共同的主题将它们串联起来。那就是“摩擦”的概念。用一个类比来解释可能会有帮助。假设你是一名设计汽车的工程师。你希望它运转得尽可能平稳，但这并不意味着你希望减少汽车所做一切事情中的摩擦力。当司机踩刹车时，正是摩擦力让汽车停下来。如果驾驶员猛拽方向盘而方向盘毫无阻力地空转，
the car could twist out of control. At the same time, if there's too much friction in the wheels, the car won't move. As an engineer, in other words, friction is essential to everything you design, but there are times you want to increase friction and times you need to decrease friction. The more Bob thought about it, the more he realized that friction works the same way in organizations. The reason many people and companies fall down when it comes to executing on their dreams is that they have too much friction in places that need to run smoothly and too little friction
汽车就会失控翻转。与此同时，如果车轮的摩擦力太大，汽车就根本开不动。换句话说，作为一名工程师，摩擦力对你设计的每一样东西都至关重要，但有时你需要增加摩擦力，有时则需要减少摩擦力。鲍勃越是思考，就越意识到摩擦力在组织中的运作方式也是如此。许多人和公司在执行梦想时之所以会掉链子，是因为他们在需要运行平稳的地方有太多的摩擦，而在需要缓慢推进的地方却又缺乏摩擦
in places that need to move slowly. When we come back, the science of friction and how you can use it to design your own life. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. All of us encounter inconveniences as we deal with cable companies, schools, and governments. At Stanford University, psychologist Bob Sutton studies the organizational origins of these frustrations.
在需要缓慢推进的地方摩擦力太少。休息之后，我们将探讨摩擦的科学，以及如何利用它来设计你自己的生活。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们在与有线电视公司、学校和政府打交道时，都遇到过各种不便。在斯坦福大学，心理学家鲍勃·萨顿研究这些挫折背后的组织根源。
Along with Huggy Rao, Bob is co-author of The Friction Project, how smart leaders make the right things easier and the wrong things harder. Bob and Huggy argue that every organization, from corner convenience stores to international aid agencies, can be plagued by destructive friction. Bob, I want to talk about a source of friction that we see in public policy all the time. You talk about a system in Michigan
鲍勃与哈吉·拉奥合著了《摩擦项目：聪明领导者如何让正确的事更容易，错误的事更难》。鲍勃和哈吉认为，从街角便利店到国际援助机构，每一个组织都可能饱受破坏性摩擦的困扰。鲍勃，我想谈谈我们在公共政策中经常看到的摩擦来源。你谈到了密歇根州的一个系统，
where residents were applying for government assistance but found it very difficult to do so. Tell me what was happening, Bob. So, there's a class that I've been teaching for years with some colleagues that's called Design Leadership. And what we do is we take a pair of students and we link them to a company or a nonprofit and help them solve a little problem.
那里的居民在申请政府援助时发现非常困难。鲍勃，能告诉我当时发生了什么吗？有一个我和同事们教了多年的课程，叫做“设计领导力”。我们的做法是把两名学生分配给一家公司或非营利组织，帮助他们解决一个小问题。
So usually these are young students, but every now and then we get somebody who visits Stanford. So this guy, his name's Michael Brennan. He was on leave from being the CEO of the United Way of Southeastern Michigan. First conversation I have, he pulls out this really long form and lays it out on the floor. It's 42 pages long. It has a thousand questions. Wow. And he says, this form is a form that is completed by more than 2 million Michigan residents a year, people who need help with food, with medical care, with financial assistance.
所以通常这些都是年轻学生，但每隔一段时间我们也会迎来一些来斯坦福访问的人。这个人名叫迈克尔·布伦南。他当时正从东南密歇根联合劝募会CEO的岗位上留职停薪。我与他的第一次对话中，他掏出了一张非常长的表格，铺在地板上。它有42页长。有一千个问题。哇。他说：“这张表格是密歇根州每年有超过200万居民填写的一张表，这些人是需要食品、医疗、经济援助帮助的人。”
And it's just, it's a terrible form. And just to give you an example of how silly the form was, my favorite or least favorite question was, when was your child conceived? Conceived, not born. Conceived, not born, conceived, not born. And he starts a nonprofit called Sevilla in southeastern Michigan. And one of their first projects was to work on trying to fix this form. And they actually made a huge amount of change in this.
而且它简直是一张糟糕透顶的表格。为了让你体会一下这张表格有多荒谬，我最喜欢或最讨厌的问题是：“你的孩子是什么时候受孕的？”是受孕，不是出生。受孕，不是出生，受孕，不是出生！他在密歇根州东南部创办了一个名为Sevilla的非营利组织。他们的首要项目之一就是致力于修复这张表格。他们实际上在这方面做出了巨大的改变，
And it's much easier for Michigan residents now to complete that form. I mean, I have to confess that every year when tax day rolls around, I feel exactly the same thing about the tax code, which is that I think of myself as a reasonably smart person, but I find it genuinely incomprehensible and almost deliberately so. Oh yes. And very often, I think that happens that no individual who assembles those forms wants to do it to us, but every person wants to add their little thing that makes them happy. That's one of the problems there.
现在密歇根州居民填写那张表格要容易得多了。我必须坦白，每年报税季到来时，我对税法也有着完全相同的感受，那就是我认为自己是一个相当聪明的人，但我发现它真的让人不可理喻，而且几乎像是故意设计成这样的。哦，是的。而且通常情况下，我认为这种情况之所以会发生，是因为汇编这些表格的任何个人都不是故意给我们添堵，而是每个人都想加上让他们自己高兴的那一点点东西。这就是其中的问题所在。
I'm imagining when it comes to something like the tax code, over time, someone somewhere has found that there's someone who cheats some aspect of the tax code. You say, let's add this other little wrinkle over here that prevents people from doing this. And if you do this sufficiently often over a hundred years, you're going to end up with something incredibly complex and difficult to understand. Yes. And one of the other problems is that in most systems,
我能想象，当涉及到类似税法这样的事情时，随着时间的推移，某个地方的某个人会发现有人在税法的某个方面作弊。你会说：“让我们在这里再加个小花招来阻止人们这样做。”如果你在一百年里足够频繁地这样做，你最终就会得到一些极其复杂且难以理解的东西。是的。另一个问题是，在大多数系统中，
the people who want to take things away, there tends to be sort of one advocate for it. And one of the things that we focus on in organizational life is that people who lead more large and complex systems and make life difficult for all of us, those are the people who tend to get rewarded, not the people who take things away. Just as an example, in my own university and I suspect many other organizations in the world, a good way if you're a manager to get a raise is to build a larger and larger organization because the more people
那些想要删减东西的人，往往只有一个人在为之发声。我们在组织生活中关注的事情之一是，那些领导着更大、更复杂系统并让我们所有人的生活变得艰难的人，往往是那些得到奖励的人，而不是那些做减法的人。举个例子，在我自己的大学里——我猜世界上许多其他组织也是如此——如果你是一名经理，想要获得加薪，一个好方法就是把组织建得越来越大，因为向你汇报的人越多，
report to you, the more you deserve to get paid, at least according to human resources. And if your team gets cut in half, sometimes you get a pay cut too. So a lot of times there's just incentives to add complexity too. You cite the example of someone who uses a wonderful phrase that I had never heard before, jargon monoxide. Tell me about that, Bob. Well, so I first heard this. There's a woman named Polly LeBeer who's been around, was a management writer for years, and she visited my classes maybe 20 years ago and she used the term jargon monoxide
根据人力资源部的说法，你就越配拿更多薪水。而如果你的团队被砍掉一半，有时你的薪水也会被削减。所以很多时候，确实存在着增加复杂性的种种激励。你引用了一个人的例子，他用了一个绝妙的词组，我以前从未听过：“行话一氧化碳”（jargon monoxide）。鲍勃，跟我讲讲这个。嗯，我最早听到这个词是在大约20年前。有个叫波莉·勒比尔的女士，她当了多年的管理作家，她大约20年前来过我的课堂，当时她使用了“行话一氧化碳”这个词，
and I've been sort of enamored with it ever since. And to us, it's hollow and confusing language and we dissect three or four different kinds of jargon monoxide. We talk about just bullsh**, just this language that means absolutely nothing. The other two kinds to me are more interesting. A second kind is what we call convoluted crap.
从那以后我就一直对它着迷。对我们来说，这是空洞且令人困惑的语言，我们剖析了三四种不同行话一氧化碳。我们谈到了纯粹的废话（bullsh**），这种语言根本没有任何意义。对我来说，另外两种更有趣。第二种是我们所说的“错综复杂的垃圾”。
This is stuff that could be simple, but it's so complicated it's impossible to understand it. And then perhaps my favorite one is jargon mishmash syndrome. So this is where you have so many different sort of languages and terms that people can't understand what is going on. And there's some situations where a word or a term means so many things to so many different people they don't know what it is. That's Danny Kahneman's definition of, is it's a random scatter of ideas.
这些东西本来可以很简单，但它被搞得如此复杂以至于根本无法理解。然后，也许我最喜欢的是“行话大杂烩综合征”。这就是指你有如此多不同的语言和术语，以至于人们根本搞不懂到底发生了什么。在某些情况下，一个词或一个术语对不同的人意味着如此多的东西，以至于他们根本不知道它是什么。这就是丹尼·卡尼曼对它的定义，它是一堆随机散落的想法。
It's not always too much friction that's the problem within organizations. Sometimes the cause of our frustrations is actually a lack of friction within organizations. One example that Bob cites is the creation of Google's smart glasses technology, known as Google Glass. Well, so Google Glass, this is one of the famous stories in Google's history. It also might be God's way of telling you you have too much money when you do stuff like this, by the way. So what happened was, so there was a team that developed essentially a set of eyeglasses that had a camera and a computer involved in it. And it was a really cool sort of prototype. And Sergey Brin, co-founder of Google, he saw the technology and he got
在组织内部，出问题的并不总是“摩擦过多”。有时，导致我们沮丧的原因恰恰是组织内部缺乏摩擦。鲍勃引用的一个例子是谷歌智能眼镜技术（即Google Glass）的诞生。谷歌眼镜，这是谷歌历史上著名的故事之一。顺便说一句，这也可能是上帝在用这种事告诉你，你的钱实在太多了。事情是这样的：有一个团队开发了一套本质上带有摄像头和电脑的眼镜。这是一个非常酷的原型产品。谷歌的联合创始人谢尔盖·布林看到了这项技术，他变得
so excited that he sort of ripped it out of the developers' hands and gave the technology to some of the most famous people in the world. And then very quickly, all the technology reviews and all the people tried to use it had battery life problems. It actually had a whole bunch of reliability problems. Oh, it had privacy problems. That was another issue. And so they ended up sort
如此兴奋，以至于他直接把技术从开发人员手中“抢”了过去，并把它交给了世界上一些最知名的人物。结果很快，所有的科技评论以及所有尝试使用它的人都遇到了电池续航问题。它实际上还存在一大堆可靠性问题。哦，它还有隐私问题。那是另一个问题。所以他们最终不得不将其
of pulling it from the market. And the technology reviews, one in particular was this is one of the worst technology projects ever made. And to us, the reason that's a lesson, and especially this idea of people who are in power sometimes don't face enough friction. His team did try to tell him that they didn't think it was a very good idea, but they kind of couldn't stop him because he had the power to rip it out of their hands and to put it into the marketplace. And there's also a sort of a postscript to that
撤出市场。科技评论中——其中有一篇尤为经典——称这是有史以来制造的最糟糕的科技项目之一。对我们来说，之所以这是一个教训——尤其是掌权的人有时不会面临足够的摩擦。他的团队确实试图告诉他，他们认为这不是一个好主意，但他们根本无法阻止他，因为他有权力从他们手中夺走技术并将其推向市场。这还有一个后续的插曲，
that many of the people involved in that project were very skilled technologists just sort of quit in frustration. That is sort of a classic story of something that was done a little bit too quickly. We've talked a little bit about the challenge of silos. You gave me the example of the hospital where you know you build a wonderful oncology department, but the oncology department doesn't talk to the hematology department, which doesn't talk to the internal medicine department. And if you're a patient, you in fact might have to interact with more than one
参与该项目的许多技术熟练的技术人员都因沮丧而纷纷辞职。这可以说是那种做得稍微快了一点的典型故事。我们刚才讨论了部门壁垒（silos）的挑战。你给我举了医院的例子：你知道，你建立了一个出色的肿瘤科，但肿瘤科不跟血液科沟通，血液科不跟内科沟通。如果你是一个病人，你事实上可能不得不与医院里的不止一个
department at the hospital, and it creates this very difficult navigational problem for patients. But you also make the very interesting point that sometimes organizations also need to have teams function a little independently, because if you don't, if you bring everyone together too soon, you can end up with an echo chamber. When people communicate and reach consensus too early and too often, you end up with, what is it, everybody thinks the same, so nobody thinks very much. And when you have independent, even competing units coming up with a solution to the problem,
科室打交道，这就给病人造成了非常困难的导诊问题。但你也提出了一个非常有趣的观点，即有时组织也需要让团队稍微独立运作，因为如果你不这样做——如果你把所有人过早地聚在一起——你最终可能会陷入一个回音室。当人们过早、过于频繁地沟通并达成共识时，你最终会得到——怎么说呢——每个人都想得一样，所以没人会想太多。而当你拥有独立甚至相互竞争的单元来提出问题的解决方案时，
sometimes you come up with better solutions. In the early days at Hewlett Packard, this is in the late 70s, early 80s when they were in the printer business, one reason they dominated so well in the printer business is they had such decentralized businesses that there were actually three or four different Hewlett Packard divisions that had their own printer in the marketplace. And although you can say, well, this was a very expensive market test, it was really dumb. But on the other hand, you did not have the problem of people having to have consensus.
有时你会得出更好的解决方案。在惠普的早期，也就是70年代末80年代初他们涉足打印机业务时，他们在打印机业务中占据主导地位的原因之一，就是他们的业务高度分散，实际上有三四个不同的惠普部门在市场上各自拥有自己的打印机。虽然你可以说，这是一次非常昂贵的市场测试，真的很愚蠢。但从另一方面来看，你并没有那种必须追求共识的问题。
You had a real test and the best product sort of won in the marketplace. So to me, that is an example. Yes, there can be some inefficiency in this case, but you certainly don't have the group thing problem. You know, I was thinking about a study that I remember reading many years ago. I think this might have been Sam Summers at Tufts University, and he was interested in the criminal justice system.
你进行了一次真正的测试，最好的产品在市场上胜出。对我来说，这就是一个例子。是的，这种情况下可能会有一些低效，但你肯定不会遇到群体思维（groupthink）的问题。你知道，我想起了一个多年前读过的研究。这似乎是塔夫茨大学的萨姆·萨默斯做的，他当时对刑事司法系统很感兴趣。
And he was looking at juries that had diverse pools of jurors versus juries that did not have diverse pools of jurors. And what he found very interestingly was that the more diverse the jury pool was, the more it prompted multiple people on the jury to challenge one another and to disagree with one another. And that disagreement obviously produced friction. It was uncomfortable. It would have been easier if everyone agreed on everything from the first moment. But of course, as you can imagine, the decisions were actually much better as a result of that friction. Another example of where friction could come in useful.
他研究了陪审团构成多元化的陪审团与构成不多元化的陪审团。他非常有趣地发现，陪审团成员的构成越多元化，就越能促使陪审团中的多个人互相质疑、互相反对。这种分歧显然会产生摩擦。这是令人不舒服的。如果从一开始大家对所有事都意见一致，事情本来会容易得多。但当然，正如你所想象的那样，由于这种摩擦，做出的决定实际上要好得多。这是摩擦可以派上用场的又一个例子。
I agree with that in having studied various elements of creativity for years. If you look at teams that are the most creative teams, they're teams that fight in an atmosphere of mutual respect. They know when to start fighting and they know when to stop fighting. A good example of this is Ed Catmull, who was president of Pixar. He would set up something that was called the Brain Trust, where all of the different people who made movies would review the dailies or the ideas for each other's films, and they'd engage in an argument in an atmosphere of mutual respect and was understood that it was your job to be critical, but not to be cruel.
我同意这一点，在研究了多年的各种创意要素之后。如果你看看最具创造力的团队，他们往往是在相互尊重的氛围中吵架的团队。他们知道什么时候开始争吵，也知道什么时候停止争吵。一个很好的例子是皮克斯的总裁埃德·卡特莫尔。他建立了一种叫做“智囊团”（Brain Trust）的机制，所有制作电影的不同人员都会聚在一起，审阅各自电影的每日毛片或构思，他们在相互尊重的氛围中展开争论，并且达成共识：你的工作是提出批判，而不是进行残酷的攻击。
So, yes, to me, that's a hallmark of creative teams. -♪ You also talk about how sometimes the longer we go through an experience, the more meaningful the experience becomes to us, which is a very interesting psychological idea where the more friction we have, the more engaged we might feel. So talk about that idea, Bob. Well, this is, you know so much about psychology, it's ridiculous.
所以，是的，在我看来，这是创意团队的一个标志。-♪ 你还谈到，有时我们经历某种体验的时间越长，这种体验对我们来说就越有意义，这是一个非常有趣的心理学观点：我们经历的摩擦越多，我们可能会觉得参与度越高。鲍勃，能谈谈这个想法吗？嗯，你知道的，你对心理学太了解了，这太离谱了。
This is a very old finding. This goes back to the 50s, the notion that labor leads to love. It's just that idea that when you put more of your heart and soul into something, it becomes more valuable to you independently of its actual value. Mm. Yeah. Yeah. You give a couple of examples in the book of people and organizations that slow down and it really benefited them. One of the examples you talk about is the company Waze, which actually got a whole bunch of funding and could have grown very quickly.
这是一个非常古老的发现。这可以追溯到50世纪（注：原文如此，应指50年代），“劳动带来爱”的概念。这正是那种理念：当你把更多的心血投入到某件事中时，无论其实际价值如何，它对你而言都会变得更有价值。嗯。对的。你在书中举了几个关于公司和组织放慢脚步从而真正受益的例子。你谈到的其中一个例子是Waze公司，它其实获得了大量融资，本可以发展得非常快。
But tell me what was happening with Waze at the time. For those of our listeners who are unfamiliar with it, first tell us what Waze is. So Waze is a navigation software that... It's more social than other navigation software, and essentially you put in the address that you want to go to and it tells you where you're going to go. So what happened in the early days of Waze, this is about 2012 or so, Noam Bardin, who is the CEO, was actually an Israeli-based company, but their primary market was in the United States. And so they got about $30 million in series B financing.
但能跟我讲讲当时Waze发生了什么吗？对于那些不熟悉的听众，请先告诉我们Waze是什么。Waze是一个导航软件……它比其他导航软件更具社交属性，基本上你输入想要去的地址，它就会告诉你该怎么走。Waze在早期——大约2012年左右，其CEO诺姆·巴丁（Noam Bardin）面临的情况是：这实际上是一家总部设在以色列的公司，但他们的主要市场在美国。他们获得了大约3000万美元的B轮融资。
And the venture capitalists who gave them the money wanted them to do two things, which are about going fast. One was to hire people. And the other thing was to do more product development. But the thing that Noam and his team figured out was that when people downloaded the software, a month later none of them were using it. So there was a problem. So what he did was he stopped the whole company, used sort of an automotive analogy, hit the brakes, and did both quantitative and qualitative analysis about why people aren't keeping our
给他们钱的风险投资家希望他们做两件事，这两件事都关于“快”。一是招聘员工；二是进行更多产品开发。但诺姆和他的团队发现的是：当人们下载了这款软件后，一个月后居然没有人再使用了。所以出问题了。于是他做了一件事：他让整个公司停下来，用汽车的类比来说，就是“踩下刹车”，并对人们为什么不继续使用我们的软件进行了定量和定性分析，
software and did no hiring and no product development. He made a list. He called it the MIT list, the most important thing list. Once they had that list, if you will, they hit the gas. They started hiring people and doing product development. Once they figured out what needed to be done, and this is very much out of Daniel Kahneman stuff on fast and slow, that when you're in a cognitive mind field, you don't rush ahead. Sometimes it's better just to stand there
期间不进行任何招聘，也不做任何产品开发。他列了一个清单。他称之为MIT清单，即“最重要的事”清单（most important thing list）。一旦他们有了这个清单，可以这么说，他们就“踩下油门”。他们开始招聘员工并进行产品开发。一旦他们弄清楚了需要做什么——这非常符合丹尼·卡尼曼关于快与慢的理论——当你在一个认知的雷区中时，你不能盲目向前冲。有时最好就站在原地，
and figure out what's going on instead of rushing ahead. ["Dreams of a New World"] In public policy, Bob, it feels like, you know, there are often times when you want to do something as a leader. If you're a president or you're a member of Congress or a senator, you want to jump ahead and you want to, you know, pass laws, implement policies. But sometimes if you try and do that too quickly, you can find things backfiring on you because
弄清楚到底发生了什么，而不是盲目前进。['《新世界之梦》'] 在公共政策方面，鲍勃，感觉好像……你知道，作为领导者，经常会有你想做点什么的时候。如果你是总统、国会议员或参议员，你会想急于求成，想通过法律、实施政策。但有时如果你试图太快地做到这一点，你可能会发现事情适得其反，因为
in fact people are not ready for the new law. They haven't been prepared for it. You haven't laid the groundwork for it Can you talk a little bit about this that in some ways? You might actually want to introduce friction as you're trying to solve important problems of public policy So that you can bring people along with you and not just impose ideas top-down Yeah, so I love that example. I think the example that for me resonates best there is That is the effort that was made by the state of Michigan
实际上人们还没有准备好迎接新法。他们还没有为此做好准备。你还没有为之奠定基础。你能稍微谈谈这一点吗？在某些方面，当你试图解决重要的公共政策问题时，你实际上可能希望引入摩擦，这样才能让人们跟你一起走，而不是仅仅自上而下地强加想法。是的，我喜欢这个例子。对我而言，最能引起共鸣的例子是
to reduce a benefit form that was completed by 2.5 million people a year. And they cut it by 80% and made it much simpler. But what they did in the process was they didn't just sort of rush in and say, the current benefits form, which is a thousand questions long and 42 pages long, and has all these silly questions. It's just dumb and we're going to fix it. First, what they did was they got the civil servants on board,
密歇根州为精简一项每年由250万人填写的福利申请表所做出的努力。他们将其删减了80%并使其变得简单得多。但在这一过程中，他们并没有简单地冲进去说：“当前的福利表有一千个问题，长达42页，还有所有这些愚蠢的问题。这简直太蠢了，我们要修复它。”首先，他们做的是让公务员们参与进来，
the head of the agency, they brought them into a room and had them fill out the 42 page form. He got to page eight and couldn't go any further. This is, this is a form required of millions of Michiganders. And then the other thing they did, which I thought was very important, was that they did develop a prototype, but then they spent about six months working with civil servants and lawyers, and they went through 1,700 pages of rules and regulations to come up with a form that was 80% shorter, but still complied with the rules.
机构负责人被请进一个房间，让他们自己去填那份42页的表格。他刚填到第八页就填不下去了。这是一份要求数百万密歇根州居民填写的表格。然后他们做的另一件事——我认为非常重要——是他们确实开发了一个原型，但随后他们花了大约六个月的时间与公务员和律师合作，翻阅了1700页的规则和条例，最终制定出了一份缩短了80%但仍然合规的表格。
And now people are filling it out much faster. There's fewer mistakes. There's fewer visits to the office because people are confused. But to your point, there was the moments when they had to slow down and bring aboard the civil servants and government leaders, and they had to slow down to make sure that their new, simple, low-friction form fit the actual rules and regulations, because otherwise they get mired in litigation, of course. Can you talk a moment about the idea of friction when it comes to bringing about change, both within organizations as well as within societies? When you think about many social movements that have brought about successful change,
现在人们填写的速度快多了，错误也更少了。因为人们不再感到困惑，去办公室的次数也减少了。但正如你所说，也有一些时刻，他们不得不放慢脚步，让公务员和政府领导参与进来，他们必须放慢节奏，确保他们这种新颖、简单、低阻力的表格符合实际的规章制度，否则他们当然会陷入无休止的诉讼之中。你能谈谈在组织内部和社会的变革过程中，关于“阻力”（friction）这个概念的看法吗？当你想到许多带来成功变革的社会运动时，
many of them have done so by actually introducing friction into the system. If you think about the civil rights movement, for example, you might have marches and protests that basically make it hard for organizations or societies to function smoothly. In some ways, introducing friction, throwing sand into the gears, is designed to say there's something wrong with the way the gears are turning. Let's slow down and figure out what needs to be fixed. Well, I mean, that's interesting. I'm not a social movement theorist, but my co-author, Hagi Rau, is.
其中许多运动之所以成功，恰恰是因为它们在系统中引入了阻力。以民权运动为例，你可能会举行游行和抗议活动，这基本上使得组织或社会难以顺畅运转。从某种意义上说，引入阻力、在齿轮中撒沙子，其目的就在于指出齿轮运转的方式出了问题。让我们慢下来，弄清楚到底需要修复什么。嗯，我的意思是，这很有趣。我不是社会运动理论家，但我的合著者哈吉·拉乌（Hagi Rao）是。
And he would argue that a lot of times when there's change in an organization or when there's change in a society, although this often can have negative side effects, that sort of forcing people to slow down and to think and to make things more difficult for them enables them to actually think. And a little bit of inconvenience for people, a little bit of struggle sometimes forces them
他会认为，很多时候，当组织或社会发生变革时，尽管这通常会带来负面副作用，但这种强迫人们慢下来、进行思考并增加难度的做法，实际上能让他们真正开始思考。人们经历的一点点不便、一点点挣扎，有时会迫使他们
to be more mindful about the challenges that they face and are imposed on others. As we've seen, friction can hurt and friction can help. As with all aspects of human behavior, the correct question to ask is not whether friction is a good thing or a bad thing, but to ask when friction is good and how much is useful. That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
对所面临的以及强加给别人的挑战保持更高的正念。正如我们所见，阻力既能造成伤害，也能提供帮助。正如人类行为的所有方面一样，正确的问题不是问阻力是好是坏，而是问阻力在什么时候是好的，以及多少阻力才是有用的。接下来我们将继续。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. Bob Sutton is an organizational psychologist at Stanford University. He studies friction, the resistance that we encounter in our daily lives, and the organizational hoops we must jump through when we pay a utility bill or get a driver's license. Friction is the inbox full of emails we comb through every morning and the meetings on our calendar that go nowhere, or being put on endless hold as we try to reach someone in customer service.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。鲍勃·萨顿（Bob Sutton）是斯坦福大学的组织心理学家。他研究阻力，也就是我们在日常生活中遇到的阻力，以及我们在缴纳水电费或办理驾照时必须经历的组织繁文缛节。阻力就是我们每天早晨要翻阅的塞满邮件的收件箱，就是日程表上毫无意义的会议，或者当我们试图联系客服时被无限期挂断的电话。
When his mother passed away some years ago, Bob found himself mired in friction. Besides dealing with his grief, he discovered he had to deal with bureaucracy. For example, he needed to update her car registration. So one morning, he headed to the Department of Motor Vehicles. Knowing that the DMV had a reputation as a bureaucratic hellhole, he dreaded the visit. I got there at 730 in the morning without an appointment and I had blocked off the entire day and I was maybe 50th in line. A fellow walks up and down the line, asks each one of us why we're there. There were some people who didn't need to be there.
几年前他的母亲去世时，鲍勃发现自己陷入了重重阻力之中。除了应对悲痛，他发现自己还必须处理官僚主义。例如，他需要更新母亲的汽车登记。于是，一天早晨，他前往机动车辆管理局（DMV）。深知DMV臭名昭著，是个官僚主义的地狱，他极其害怕这次造访。我早上7点30分到那儿，没预约，我空出了整整一天的时间，排队可能排在第50位左右。有个家伙在队伍里走来走去，问我们每个人来这里是为了什么。有些人根本没必要来。
For example, one fellow was there for a passport. They don't provide passports, so he said he should leave. He gave us forms, and then he sent me to the window I was supposed to go. So he was doing triage, and I was out of there by 8.15, and I was completely confused about how quickly and easily it happened. And he was somebody, we'd call him somebody who was a trustee of others' time, a friction fixer,
例如，有个家伙是来办护照的。他们不办理护照，所以他说他应该离开。他发给我们表格，然后把我指引到我应该去的窗口。所以他在做分诊（triage），我在8点15分之前就离开了那里，而且我对事情发生得如此迅速和容易感到非常困惑。他就是那种我们称之为“他人时间的托管人”、“阻力消除者”（friction fixer）的人，
who I initially thought he just took it upon himself to do it. So we have since found out that there's a large scale effort to improve both the speed and emotional experience of going through the DMV. You used a very interesting word a second ago, and the word was triage, because of course when this person came out 15 minutes before the doors opened and basically said, let me send people to different places, this person actually is waiting for a passport, that's
我起初以为他只是自发地去做这件事。后来我们发现，其实有一个大规模的行动，旨在改善通过DMV办理业务的速度和情感体验。刚才你用了一个非常有趣的词，这个词就是“分诊”，因为当这个人甚至在门开前15分钟走出来，基本上说“让我把人们指引到不同的地方，这个人实际上是在等护照，那
not the right, you can't get into the DMV, this person needs to go counter number six, this person needs to fill out a form. There's just a whole bunch of information and time that this person ended up saving by stepping out for 15 minutes because of course the person knows everything that you can get at the DMV, one person that knows everything. Can you talk about this idea? It's such a profound idea because I think many organizations don't have a person like that. When you go to a hospital, there's often no one actually playing triage that basically says, here's how you navigate our organization, because that's what this person was doing.
不是对的，你不能进DMV，这个人需要去6号柜台，这个人需要填一张表”时，通过花15分钟走出来，这个人最终节省了大量的信息和时间，因为这个人当然知道你在DMV能得到的一切，一个无所不知的人。你能谈谈这个想法吗？这是一个非常深刻的想法，因为我认为许多组织都没有这样的人。当你去医院时，通常没有人真正在扮演分诊的角色，基本上对你说，“这就是你如何在我们组织中通行的方法”，因为这正是这个人所做的。
That's exactly what that person was doing. That's one of our solutions. We talk about how friction fixers, yes, in an ideal world, they'll fix things on the team or the organization, but one of the hallmarks of people who are great at understanding what is available and what aren't, they're sort of tour guides through the system. And we talk in the book about Greece people and gunk people, and I'll name a name, in my department, Management, Science and Engineering, there's a woman named Lori Cottle, who's our head of student services. She's been there almost as long as I have. Maybe she's been there only 27 years.
这正是那个人在做的事。这也是我们的解决方案之一。我们谈到阻力消除者时，是的，在理想世界中，他们会解决团队或组织中的问题，但那些非常善于理解什么可行、什么不可行的人的一个标志，就是他们某种程度上是系统中的导游。我们在书中谈到了“润滑剂型人才”（Greece people）和“阻碍剂型人才”（gunk people），我举个具体的例子，在我的部门——管理科学与工程系，有一位名叫洛里·科特尔（Lori Cottle）的女士，她是我们的学生服务主管。她在那儿的工作时间几乎和我一样长。也许她只在那儿工作了27年吧。
And Lori sees it as her job to make every student's journey throughout Stanford as easy and satisfying as possible. And she'll tell you who to talk to, who not to talk to. She'll tell you which rules are completely inflexible and which ones you can get around and how to get around them. And to me, somebody like her is an absolutely beautiful part of a system. And she maybe she's changed a few rules, but mostly she knows how the system works.
洛里把她的工作视为让每个学生在斯坦福的求学之旅尽可能轻松、满意。她会告诉你该和谁谈，不该和谁谈。她会告诉你哪些规定是绝对不可通融的，哪些规定你可以绕过，以及如何绕过它们。对我来说，像她这样的人绝对是系统中极其美好的一部分。她也许修改过几条规定，但主要是她深谙系统的运作方式。
And she sees it as her job to help you have the best journey you can through the system as a as a Stanford student. She advises undergraduates, masters and PhD students in our department, and they all have a different set of rules, and she all helps them get through a fairly complicated system as easily as possible. And this must be true not just at universities, but at organizations across the board. As organizations get bigger, they get more complex. There are more ways in which things fit together or don't fit together. There are organizational and institutional histories that people might not know if they're
她将帮助你作为斯坦福学生在系统中获得最佳旅程视为自己的工作。她为我们系本科生、硕士生和博士生提供咨询，他们每个人都适用一套不同的规则，而她帮助所有人尽可能轻松地穿过这个相当复杂的系统。这不仅在大学里如此，在各行各业的组织中也一定如此。随着组织越来越大，它们也变得越来越复杂。事物之间相互契合或不契合的方式更多了。如果人们是第一次
encountering the organization for the first time. Having someone play this role, and you use the word tour guide, I might use the word translator because I think that's the other role that this person is playing, to say, here's how this section of the organization talks to this other section of the organization. So invaluable. Yes. And to me, very often people like that, and I think of organizations with silos and occupations, very often they're people who are generalists in a sea of specialists that they know enough
接触该组织，他们可能并不了解其中的组织历史和制度历史。让某人扮演这个角色——你用了“导游”这个词，我可能会用“翻译”这个词，因为我认为这是这个人扮演的另一个角色，即指出“组织的这一部分是如何与组织的另一部分对话的”。这太宝贵了。是的。对我来说，常常有这样的人——我想到的是存在部门壁垒和不同职业的组织——他们往往是一群专才之中的通才，他们对
about how each part works to sort of glue the system together and to serve as tour guides for all of us. You talk about a very interesting idea called the rule of halves. What is the rule of halves, Bob? So the rule of halves, this is an idea that actually Lydie Klotz, he and I came up with the notion that as sort of a thought experiment, if you went through the number of meetings you have, the length of the emails, the number of emails you sent, what would happen if you cut it by 50%? And then the example we use in the book comes to us from a guy named Rob Cross.
各个部分如何运作有着足够的了解，从而将整个系统粘合在一起，并为我们所有人都充当导游。你谈到了一个非常有趣的概念，叫做“减半法则”（rule of halves）。什么是“减半法则”，鲍勃？所以，“减半法则”这个概念其实是莉迪·克洛茨（Lydie Klotz）和我共同想出来的。作为一个思想实验，如果你审视一下你开会的数量、邮件的长度、你发送的邮件数量，如果你把它们削减50%，会发生什么？我们在书中使用的例子来自一个叫罗布·克罗斯（Rob Cross）的人。
He was working with an executive, a guy named Scott, who had about 5,000 employees reporting to him. And he also had 16 direct reports. And he also had this philosophy that he should be involved in all decisions. And one of the things that Rob Cross did with him as sort of a consulting job is he said, we're going to cut everything by 50%. The number of direct reports you have, the number of emails you send, the number of meetings you go to.
他曾与一位高管合作，这个人叫斯科特（Scott），手下大约有5,000名员工向他汇报。他还有16个直接下属。他还有一个理念，即自己应该参与所有的决策。罗布·克罗斯与他合作时采取的咨询工作之一就是对他说：“我们要把所有东西削减50%。你的直接下属人数、你发送的邮件数量、你参加的会议数量。”
And it turned out that this guy saved his job and saved his marriage, as Rob tells it, because he actually did apply the rule of halves. So we're not saying to all of your listeners, you should cut everything by 50%, but it's a good sort of thought experiment to start with. And it was kind of fun because Lydie Klotz and I, I don't know if it's his idea or my idea, but we give each other credit.
正如罗布所说，事实证明这个人不仅保住了工作，还拯救了婚姻，因为他确实应用了“减半法则”。所以我们并不是对所有的听众说，你们应该把所有东西都削减50%，但这确实是一个很好的开端思想实验。这挺有意思的，因为莉迪·克洛茨和我——我不知道这究竟是他的主意还是我的主意，但我们总是把功劳归于对方。
But in some ways, I think what you're saying is that if an organization has a set of policies or rules and you cut the policies in half or cut the rules in half, it doesn't mean that that has to be your final answer. You might still decide you actually need to add back many rules that you've cut, but just the thought experiment, the effect of basically saying, let me cut it in half and see what actually is essential, jolts our minds, I think, into awareness
但在某种程度上，我认为你想表达的是，如果一个组织有一套政策或规则，而你把这些政策或规则削减一半，这并不意味着这就是你的最终答案。你可能仍然会觉得其实需要把许多删减掉的规则加回来，但仅仅是这个思想实验——基本上说“让我把它削减一半，看看究竟什么才是必不可少的”这一做法——我认为会猛然唤醒我们的意识，让我们意识到
of how complex our systems have become. Yeah, yes. Another also related example, which we talk about in the book and was based on a little piece that I wrote with Rebecca Hines, who was, Rebecca Hines is a wonderful person. She was involved as our research assistant from the very beginning as an undergraduate, and now she runs something called the Asana Work Innovation Lab. She's actually hiring professors instead of working for them. And so we did this little piece on, we called it a team reset, and it was with 60 Asana employees,
我们的系统变得多么复杂。是的，没错。另一个相关的例子我们在书中也有提及，它基于我和丽贝卡·海因斯（Rebecca Hines）共同写的一小篇文章。丽贝卡·海因斯是个非常优秀的人。她从一开始还是个本科生的时候就作为我们的研究助理参与其中，现在她经营着一家名为“Asana工作创新实验室”（Asana Work Innovation Lab）的机构。她现在其实是雇佣教授，而不是为教授工作。所以我们写了这篇小文章，我们称之为“团队重置”（team reset），对象是60名Asana员工，
and what she did with 30 of those 60s is that she had them remove all standing meetings from their calendars for 48 hours, and then after evaluating, if you will, the amount of effort and the value of each one, add them back in. That to me, that's a complete cleanse and that's this idea of once you take something away, it forces you
她让这60人中的其中30人在48小时内从日历中删除了所有例行会议，然后在评估了每个会议的精力和价值之后，再决定将哪些加回来。对我来说，这是一次彻底的净化，这就是那种一旦你拿走某些东西，就会强迫你
to think about whether you actually want to put it back in. And by the way, that team reset experience saved the average employee about four hours a week. You tell a remarkable story about Winston Churchill during the very difficult days of World War II, focused not on the Nazi war machine, but on bureaucrats in Britain. Tell me that story, Bob. This is August 1940. The Blitzkrieg started a month later. And what he did is he sent out a 234 word memo called the brevity memo.
去思考你是否真的想把它重新加回来的理念。顺便说一句，那次团队重置的经历平均每周为每位员工节省了大约四个小时的时间。你讲了一个关于温斯顿·丘吉尔在第二次世界大战极其艰难的日子里的非凡故事，他的注意力不是放在纳粹战争机器上，而是放在英国的官僚身上。把那个故事讲给我听听，鲍勃。那是1940年8月。闪电战在一个月后开始。他当时做的是发出了一份长达234字的备忘录，被称为“精简备忘录”（brevity memo）。
And he said, please stop writing such long convoluted detailed memos. It's slowing down the whole system. He said it much more elegantly than that. And then he also added this notion that that the length and number of memos that are written by an ambassador is not an indication of the quality of your work. And by the way, and this is consistent with our notion that friction fixing is sort of like mowing the lawn, there is no one and done. When he came back, because those of us who know the history, he was Prime Minister during World War II, but then he got voted out and then he came back some years later.
他说，请停止撰写如此冗长、迂回、细节繁琐的备忘录。这正在拖慢整个系统的运转。他说得比这优雅得多。然后他还补充了一个观点，即大使撰写的备忘录的长度和数量并不是工作质量的指标。顺便说一句，这与我们的理念一致——消除阻力就像修剪草坪一样，没有一劳永逸这回事。当他重返政权时——因为了解历史的人都知道，他是二战期间的首相，但后来在选举中落败，数年后又卷土重来——
When he came back in the 50s, he wrote more brevity memos and said it was even worse than before. So it is one of those things that you've got to have the discipline to keep fighting over and over again. There's no one and done with this sort of stuff. Because of course things will keep growing back because of the addition sickness that we all suffer from. Yes, yes. We are just humans. A crucial lesson that runs through many of these ideas is the lesson of empathy.
当他在50年代再次上台时，他写了更多的精简备忘录，并表示情况甚至比以前更糟了。所以这是那种你必须保持纪律、不断抗争的事情。这类事情根本没有一劳永逸。因为事物当然会不断卷土重来，这是因为我们所有人都有着“做加法的病”（addition sickness）。是的，没错。我们只是凡人。贯穿许多这些理念的一个核心教训就是“同理心”（empathy）的教训。
Organizations, companies, and governments often run poorly because the people making the decisions are divorced from the experience of the people who work in the organization and the people who need the services of the organization. One of Bob's superheroes when it comes to fixing problems with friction is an executive at General Motors named Mary Berra. Every person I've ever worked with just loves her and the number of different jobs she's had at General Motors are amazing. She ran a large plant, she was head of manufacturing, she's had at General Motors are amazing. She ran a large plant. She was head of manufacturing. She was head of supply chain.
组织、公司和政府之所以经常运转不佳，是因为做出决策的人脱离了组织内部员工的体验，也脱离了需要组织服务的人的体验。在解决阻力问题方面，鲍勃的超级英雄之一是通用汽车（General Motors）的一位高管，名叫玛丽·巴拉（Mary Barra）。我共事过的每个人都非常喜欢她，她在通用汽车担任过的不计其数的不同职位令人惊叹。她管理过一个大型工厂，曾任制造主管，她在通用汽车担任过的职位令人惊叹。她管理过一个大型工厂。她曾任制造主管。她曾任供应链主管。
She was head of HR before they brought her in. So rather than being somebody who just is sort of focused on one element of running this large complex organization, she understands how it runs. And then the other thing she does, since we interviewed a number of people who worked with her, is she's the classic person who makes very strong decisions, but she always waits to hear everybody's opinion and then she says, we're going to do this. And I think that's a hallmark of a good leader who glues together different elements of an organization. They hear all the opinions, but then they also make a clear decision about what should
在他们将她提拔上来之前，她曾任人力资源主管。所以，她不是那种只关注运营这个庞大复杂组织某一特定要素的人，她深刻理解它是如何运转的。另一件她会做的事——既然我们采访了许多与她共事过的人——是她属于那种典型的能够做出非常果断决策、但总是耐心倾听所有人意见、然后说“我们就这么办”的人。我认为这是一个能够将组织不同要素粘合在一起的优秀领导者的标志。他们倾听所有的意见，但随后也会对该做什么和不该做什么做出清晰的决定。
and shouldn't be done. Because leaders who have unclear messages talk about creating friction, you're going to spend all sorts of time discerning what the boss actually means. I think partly what we're saying here is over and over, you need people who understand how different parts of an organization fit together. And especially as organizations get big and complex, someone who has worked in HR and has worked in supply chain and has worked in finance and has worked in this, that, and the other, knows how these things actually interact with each other and has seen how the problem looks from different
因为传达信息不明确的领导者会制造阻力，你会花各种各样的时间去揣摩老板到底是什么意思。我想这里我们反复要表达的部分意思是，你需要那些理解组织不同部分如何契合在一起的人。特别是随着组织变得庞大和复杂，某个曾经在人力资源、供应链、财务以及这方面、那方面都工作过的人，才知道这些事物究竟是如何相互影响的，并且已经从不同的
points of view. Yes, I think that's absolutely true. And to me, that's sort of the hallmark of somebody who's a good friction fixer because they're always learning more about how different pieces of the system fit together. So Bob, you've been married for nearly 40 years as we're having this conversation. Your 40th wedding anniversary is coming up next year.
角度看清了问题所在。是的，我认为这绝对是真的。对我来说，这正是一个优秀的阻力消除者（friction fixer）的标志，因为他们总是在不断学习系统各个部分是如何组合在一起的。那么，鲍勃，在我们进行这次对话时，你已经结婚近40年了。你的40周年结婚纪念日将在明年到来。
Talk about the idea of friction in relationships and when they're useful, when they're not, how they've played a role in your life. Well, yeah. Well, I guess the opening line, what's the Supreme's song? You can't hurry love. So my wife Marina, who is a lawyer, she's a rational person, we do not make decisions quickly in our family if they're important. And so we started living together when I was 21 and she was 19. And we lived together seven years before we got married. And the story is that, so I'm an academic and at this point, it was a brand new academic
谈谈人际关系中的阻力这个概念，它们在什么时候是有用的，什么时候是没有用的，它们在你的生活中是如何发挥作用的。好吧，是的。嗯，我想开场白是，至高合唱团（The Supremes）的那首歌怎么唱来着？“欲速则不达”（You can't hurry love）。所以我的妻子玛丽娜（Marina）是一名律师，她是一个理性的人，如果要做重要决定，我们在家里是绝不会仓促行事的。我们从我21岁、她19岁时就开始同居了。我们在结婚前一起生活了七年。故事是这样的，我是个学者，当时我是一个全新的学者，
at Stanford. I was just starting to, you know, to be considered for the tenure process. And my late father-in-law's name was Rod Park. He stood up and gave us a toast. He was at that time he was provost at UC Berkeley. He understood academics. And he said, so Bob is used to a seven-year tenure clock. And at seven years, they make a decision up or out.
刚到斯坦福。我当时刚开始进入，你知道的，准备接受终身教职（tenure）评审的阶段。我已故岳父的名字叫罗德·帕克（Rod Park）。他站起来给我们祝酒。他当时是加州大学伯克利分校的教务长。他懂学术界。他说，所以鲍勃习惯了七年的终身教职考核期。到了七年，他们会做一个决定，要么留下，要么走人。
And he said, Marina has made the same decision. She's given him the seven-year test, and it's up. So that was sort of the beginning of that, and you can't hurry love. It takes a long time. And some people do get married after their first dates, but I'm not sure that's a good idea. But can you talk about the idea that in some ways, relationships themselves are, you know, they're not like products.
他说，玛丽娜也做出了同样的决定。她给了他七年的考验期，现在时间到了。所以这基本上就是那个开始，“欲速则不达”。这需要很长时间。有些人确实在第一次约会后就结婚了，但我不敢确定那是不是个好主意。但是你能谈谈这种观点吗？在某些情况下，人际关系本身，你知道的，它们不像产品。
They're not things that you can rush to market. They're things that in fact take time and they grow and they ripen and they ripen at their own speed. And sometimes hurrying them along or wishing that they were something that they are not is a fool's errand. Yes, it is a fool's errand. And if we're going to do a little bit more empirically, there are a whole set of studies,
它们不是那种你可以匆忙推向市场的东西。它们是需要时间、需要成长、需要成熟、并且按照它们自己的速度成熟的东西。有时催促它们，或者希望它们成为它们本不属于的样子，简直是白日做梦。是的，这纯粹是白日做梦。如果我们说得更具实证性一点，其实有一整套研究表明，
and sometimes academics call this prior joint experience. But you can look at startups that are founded by people who have worked together. They tend to be more successful at Stanford, way back to Ulrich Packard. Instagram was founded by people who worked together before Intuit. You can look at research on surgery that if your anesthesiologist and
有时学者们称之为“先前的共同经验”（prior joint experience）。但你可以看看由曾经共事过的人所创立的初创公司。他们在斯坦福往往更成功，比如追溯到乌尔里希·帕克（Ulrich Packard）。Instagram就是由以前在一起工作过的人创立的，Intuit也是。你可以看看关于外科手术的研究，如果你的麻醉师和
surgeon have done more procedures together, especially at the same hospital, your outcomes are likely to be better. There is a point where relationships get stale and you've got to make things fresh, but this idea of when people have worked together before that they tend to be more effective, especially for difficult, complex tasks, is something that's very important. So this notion that working things out takes time is important. Bob Sutton is a psychologist at the Stanford School of Engineering. With Hagi Rao, he is co-author of The Friction Project, How Smart Leaders Make the Right
外科医生一起做过更多手术，特别是在同一家医院，你的手术结果往往会更好。当然，人际关系也会有变得陈旧、需要注入新鲜感的时候，但这种“当人们曾经一起共事过时，他们往往会更高效”的理念，特别是在面对困难、复杂的任务时，是非常重要的。所以，解决问题需要时间这个概念至关重要。鲍勃·萨顿是斯坦福大学工程学院的心理学家。他与哈吉·拉乌合著了《阻力项目：精明领导者如何化繁为简、让对的事情更轻松、让错的事情更难》（The Friction Project: How Smart Leaders Make the Right Things Easier and The Wrong Things Harder）。鲍勃，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。哦，尚卡尔，这太棒了。非常感谢你对这本书读得如此仔细。我感觉自己好像在参加一场针对一本我花了七年时间写作、甚至自己都忘了某些部分的书的测验。所以谢谢你。好吧，你得了A加，鲍勃，你得了A加。谢谢。
Things Easier and The Wrong Things Harder. Bob, thanks so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Oh, Shankar, it's just been remarkable. And thank you for reading the book so closely. I felt like I've had a quiz on a book that I spent seven years writing and I even forgot some parts. So thank you. Well, you get an A plus, Bob, you get an A plus. Thank you.
谢谢。
Thank you. Oh. Oh. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you know someone who would enjoy today's episode or any of the
哦。哦。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏的大脑传媒（Hidden Brain Media）制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗（Annie Murphy-Paul）、克里斯滕·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·奎雷尔（Laura Quirell）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。如果你认识某位会喜欢今天这期节目或我们
episodes in our Innovation 2.0 series, please share it with them. Your word-of-mouth recommendations make a huge difference in helping to connect new listeners to the ideas we explore on Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam, see you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“创新2.0”系列中任何一期节目的人，请与他们分享。你的口碑推荐对于将新听众连接到我们在《隐藏的大脑》中探讨的理念上起到了巨大的作用。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，我们回头见。你 这集节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。